I mean it's continuing we've we are
aware that more planes will be going
into Horton to evacuate more foreign
Nationals the Italian plane came in
earlier today with 140 Nash foreign
Nationals Italian and other from other
countries in the EU and expecting
another plane to go in to evacuate more
I spoke to the daughter of an Irish
citizen who was flown in on the French
plane and was contacted by his by the
Irish Embassy in hartum and asked to
meet at the French military base just a
little bit outside of hartum in what
they called a an initiative to bring
together EU citizens and evacuate them
from the country as we landed here in
Djibouti we saw military planes on the
on the on the tarmac we saw a massive
Canadian military plane ready to go it
seems but also we saw German diplomats
gathered a welcome Committee of sorts
with with German flags small German
flags ready to meet German Nationals as
they came out so evacuation efforts are
not only underway but they seem to be in
full swing fighting was there was a lull
in fighting though there was fighting it
did continue There was a lull in
fighting I think to allow for the safe
passage of foreign Nationals but the
fear is now that so many have been
evacuated what does this mean for
Sudanese Nationals and dual citizens who
aren't able to be evacuated will they be
left behind and trapped in their homes
or will they be evacuated
and you said just to um clarify the
situation at the moment is is fighting
still ongoing
yeah fighting is ongoing I mean just
this hour there was fighting that
blocked evacuation route out of the city
as many people have been taking buses
going to the border with Egypt going to
the Border in the East to Port Sudan
trying to make their way out and there's
expected to be an intensification of
fighting tomorrow the sources in the
Army say that they're planning to launch
an on-ground uh offensive against the
rsf many rsf militiamen are hiding
people's homes they looted people's
homes but they basically told them to
leave and took shelter there so the the
worry is is that the fighting keeps kind
of being concentrated and in densely
populated urban areas more and more
people will die
Yeshua thank you for the update